[Music]
let's go to phoenix
and talk to mrs shawna what's up shauna
hey doctor john how's it going man we
are rocking onto the break of dawn how
about you
i'm all right um
really how are you i just heard about
your accident
oh man
yeah i guess the show went out today
um yeah i'm getting there it's uh my
something happened to my ribs man i'm
still not breathing right but um i'm
doing i'm doing good i'm doing good i
did get the uh
estimate back on the prius and the
breeze was officially
prius is dead the prius is gone
no more so such it is but thank you for
asking you're too kind
heck of a way to start the day i tell
you what that's exactly right
so what's up yeah so the reason for my
call is i'm really concerned about my
husband because
he has no friends
and when i say
he has no friends i mean he has
zero
nobody that he gets together with hangs
out with
calls up has a beer dinner whatever
nobody the only person he talks to aside
from me is his mom uh oh
how old is he yeah
he is going to be 64 this year oh okay
yeah so his mom is mom
has mom always been
uh
yeah
kind of like the
jellyfish with the tentacles around
everything
uh-huh yes you've been married to two
people most of your marriage
you know that's exactly what my
counselor has said
three people in your marriage yes i'm
making this up as i go that's that feels
good
um wow
oh man yeah
so so
something's happened recently where
you're concerned what's going on
um his mom is you know certainly she's
not gonna be around forever she's
getting up there in age and he can't
even talk about it you know just like
we talked about you know wills and and
trusts and all that so he won't even
broach the subject
period
so it's like
it's gonna happen someday yep
i'm the only one
here for you and
you know i just don't think it's healthy
so it's it's absolutely absolutely not
um
and it's not the fact that he's a 65
year old man who loves his mom and takes
care of mom that's that's not the
unhealthy part the unhealthy part is
they're still acting as though she's 22
and he's six
yeah
um he just brought you along for that
ride
yeah how long have you been there
i think the table's turned i think he's
the one that's 22 and she's six oh
because she just hovers over her wow
how's your marriage
um it's
we struggle yeah we're in counseling
um i think
we've struggled for a long time and i
think the only reason that we're
together is we're both committed to
making it work
but you're not making it work
we're struggling yeah but we're in
counseling and and you know
so you're not making some progress for
the first time good so you're not
committed to making it work you're
committed to not quitting
because commitment to making it work
means we're gonna have super hard
conversations and i'm i'm going to and
he's going to do things that are really
uncomfortable for us to grow so it
sounds like you're committed to not
ending it but you're
you're getting there and i and here let
me say this
the fact that he's willing to go is a
real brave step i don't know a lot of
that courageous and that strong of men
who at 65 will say i need to go talk to
somebody with my wife because we're not
okay good for him that's good and good
for you for dragging him kicking and
screaming um and that was it yeah hey it
wasn't he wasn't like he went willingly
sure
so ultimately i
this might be unfair and i don't care
i want you in your home and with your
counselor to begin to discuss his
relationship with his mom as an
addiction
because what she
not her
but his interaction with her his
relationship with her is allowing him to
numb out and not deal with reality and
that's what addiction is
and so the only way to deal with
addiction is to
get off the drug
and so when we think about it in terms
of relationship we say i can't leave mom
hanging i can't mom has to i have to
right so we make it about a bunch of
tasks and a bunch of obligations and a
bunch of shoulds
if you spend a season looking at mom as
heroin
that is killing us that is killing you
then now we're gonna approach dealing
with that relationship differently
and that might mean for a season that
you
are the one who's gonna go over and make
sure your mom's gutters are or you're
going to call the guy that's going to
fix the gutters and you might be the one
that goes over and talks to mom about
the will the conversation with the wheel
is happening if you don't want to do it
fine i'm going to be the one right so
that may be that you fill in the gap for
a little while which is absolutely not
something you want to do with your other
wife right but
it may be the way that he slowly weans
himself off but if he doesn't
man hey
when this call is over hang on the line
i'm going to send you a copy of my new
book own your past change your future
and it's they're ordered oh you did well
i'm gonna send you another one that way
y'all can read it together okay
um but
something about his past it says
marriage is not safe somebody else isn't
safe this is become this interaction
with mom he totally controls interesting
feels like a warm blanket for him so
what about
your marriage is unsafe
well
for him his his ex-wife
walked out on him
all coming together james we should
start a podcast
yeah we should do this for a living
so he has
um
the first most important or the second
most important woman in his life after
mom walked out on him
gone
right
so his body
remembers that
and so i blamed mom for being a
jellyfish and you corrected me and you
corrected me correctly so he wrapped his
tentacles around the first most
important woman in his life and said
this will be it
and then he wanted some romance and you
can't kiss your mom so he got married
again and he i'm confident he loves you
right how long have you all been married
uh 13 years okay so you all been in it
for more than a decade
um
but there's it i would be stunned if
there wasn't some side eye in the side
of so in the
special parts of his brain that are just
waiting for you to leave
oh i agree with that 100 percent and
what becomes
becomes
he said that okay so here's what stinks
about that
is
for whatever reason or those kind of
thoughts become self-reinforcing
and when there's a part of his brain
waiting for something to happen
then it leans one centimeter away from
the the blast or two inches away from
the blast
and you feel that gap
and you respond to that gap whether
you're conscious of it or not with
either being overly clingy or he just
needs a space and i'm just going to go
do this and then you look up 10 years
later and you've created a life he's
created a life and you're still sharing
a bed
exactly
and then you get that two inches apart 2
000 miles away from each other
yeah
um
and while he has
no friends i have a lot of friends yep
so
um is he unpleasant to be around i'm
just being honest like if you invited a
couple
some couples over to the house and
they're
you know
unsociable husbands showed up is he fun
to be around or did he go hide in the
back room
he no he's fun to be around
um i don't know that he
i mean actually when there's other
people around i kind of look at him and
i'm like who are you because you are not
that person at home
but um
i don't know that he's comfortable in
that environment i mean i do get us
together with other couples
um not frequently but um
he's fine he seems fine in those
situations
but the fact that he doesn't have
friends leads me to believe i mean i
don't know what's going on between him
and
other guys
like that he used to work with or
whatever
so one of the great tragedies of our
time is the loneliness of adult men
we have no our dads didn't i mean our
dads didn't have friends
our dads went to work and worked
themselves to death literally if you
look at the data
and we don't have a picture of what
adult male friendship looks like
and so
and then man we create fantasy leagues
and we create video games we create
streaming services and now we really
don't have to leave and now making adult
male friends as an adult is
um
one of the physiologically scariest
things our bodies can absorb because we
want to belong
and that's not a want like oh i just
want to belong that's a that's a core
psychological physiological need
the other side of that which is really
hard to interp to come to grips with is
when our body recognizes that we're
lonely it goes to war against us
and so you either have to risk
and lean over that edge and say i know i
need friends
or
you die a painful
slow
uh incapacitating death and you take
people around you with you
and that's why you're calling
so i've yeah i've tried to encourage him
i'm well why don't you call someone on
google finger why don't you call someone
so
you know he just feels like
it i think there's more to it as well as
as far as the lack of
you know it's like well they've got
other things that's my life i'm a burden
i know that they need to take care of it
yeah exactly i'm a burden they don't
want to hang out with me or
we're going to get to hole five of the
golf course and i don't know i don't
know what we're going to talk about so
i'm just let's just stay here or i
talked to one guy who was like man why
would i go skiing i'm just going to get
up water skiing i'm just going to get up
i'm going to get my swim trunks on and
go get the boat in the water and we're
going to drive around and get all hot
and i'm going to end up back and then
we're going to get tired i'm going to
end up in the same chair that this
tonight why don't i just stay here
and
if you're running low if you're lonely
if you're depressed if you are if
relationships have hurt you in the past
that has a logic to it it makes sense
it's true we are we're gonna end up
right back here
um
and unfortunately you end up missing all
of life whether it's movement whether
it's outdoors whether it's nature
whether it's companionship and
friendship etc
the only way i've seen this thing shift
is to one of two ways one is
it's by association
one of the one of the partners so in
this case you
says hey from this point forward every
friday night we're having
these couples over
and just truth be told my wife do that
to me
um i i i've had some deep bouts of
profound loneliness in my life and what
really stinks about that is i've got
men and women in my life who i love and
i've been friends with for years and
years and years but i have a tendency to
isolate myself
i just get home and i'm tired and i just
loop a blanket of the distraction around
me and then i call it good so she said
we're having people over every weekend
forever for the rest of our lives
and so
what i had to come to terms with was
there's always gonna be people in my
house and so i can make peace with it or
i can go to war with it and i decided to
make peace with it and now i
i miss it dearly
that's number one number two was i had a
stark oh my goodness um
it's john uh
c-a-c-c-i-p-p-o
castillapo is that how you say it
wrote the he wrote the book called
loneliness and i read that book as a
scientist and
i remember
it was like reading a book about the
damages of smoking or reading a book
about you know particular nutrition
stuff it was a bellwether moment i
bought it for multiple people in my life
but i read it and realized oh if you
don't do this you're going to die
it's going to kill you and it's going to
be real unpleasant way to die too by
strokes and cancer and heart disease and
things like that and so those two things
the ra the reality of that data helped
me to change
and my wife's commitment to i'm just
gonna surround you with people you're
gonna get over this or you're just gonna
have to go sit under the under our bed
while the house is full of people who
love you and i opted for number two
and it's it's uh i'm super super
grateful that she leaned in that way
and i've got friends who won't let me
won't let me go either and vice versa
but
um
it sounds like you've got that extra
thing where you have friends and that's
kind of one of the reasons that i reach
out to you because i i in listening to
myself for so long i know that you value
friendship it's everything and yeah and
it's sad that he has it and his mom
doesn't either yeah it's not like yeah
it's a model he doesn't have he doesn't
have a picture for it
um and there's a few men in my life like
todd and john and trevor and craig and
others that
they taught me what friendship looked
like ryan and caleb and chris these guys
have been in my life for years and years
for decades and decades they taught me
what it looks like
they kept showing up right and so it's
hard when you don't have that
that's where
your influence in his life will be big
and a counselor's influence in his life
will be big
the the
the challenge with trauma especially
when it comes relational trauma whether
it's any type of uh sexual abuse or
physical abuse or any type of abuse is
it weaponizes the very thing that keeps
us alive it weaponizes a relationship so
somewhere in there
relationships equal scary
relationships equal pain and until he
decides i'm gonna make a move past that
um he's gonna continue to choose safety
which makes total sense i get it
um but yeah mom's gonna go and all of a
sudden yet another important woman in
his life is going to be gone
and you you almost you see that car
wreck happening in slow motion right
yeah yeah
so number one he's lucky to have you
like
the number of men who would call my show
and be like dude i wish my wife would
tell me to go golfing or fishing or
something good for you good for loving
him so much that you know that he needs
other people that's amazing yeah number
two i would make a commitment to the
house is gonna be full of people
and i see you husband come alive when we
do this and so we're gonna do it and
then the third thing is
i would be really clear in your
counseling sessions in your counseling
meetings to talk about his loneliness
your desire for him to have friends
your commitment to put money out there
or time out there whatever that looks
like
and let's be really clear about the data
the
data of loneliness
so let's do this we're gonna take a
break real quick we're gonna come back
and i'll run through a little bit of
that data with you um stay on the line
shauna we're gonna send you another copy
of the book that you can read give him
and y'all can read it together and um
man i'm so grateful that you called let
us know how this thing plays out because
i'm interested and my hope is that he
gets a couple of grumpy old men that
will join him in whatever adventures
he's he wants to go on here for the last
20 30 years of his life